you did some time bartending in san
diego i did now i would have to think
you bartending san diego single guy must
be the most amazing way to meet women
right
yeah it was pretty good how could it not
be good women always love the bartender
don't they they do you know the
interesting thing about bartending is
the
the tables kind of turn a little because
people got to come up to you for the
drink
they sort of want something from you so
uh you have a little bit of an edge
right yeah so i'd like to i think maybe
like remake cocktail would be a good
a good movie
would you want a remake yeah yeah why
not would you want the tom cruise roll
yeah okay that would be great you guys
familiar with cocktail okay yeah
you know i when i heard about the idea
for that movie that it's just about a
guy who tends bar and he's really good
at it i thought it can't be done and
then i saw that movie
and i thought it can't be done no i'm
kidding
where's the thing i was i was like the
world's worst bartender because he's in
that movie he's flipping drinks oh he's
incredible he's incredible
and i was the opposite so i'd have to
make the movie but be like the world's
worst bartender
really so you wouldn't be flipping
drinks at all they could do that with
cgi you know they can't they could shoot
your scenes where you're just like this
and then later on other hands
do all this incredible stuff and you're
just looking right to camera and people
be like he's better than cruz better
than cruz
so you are not a good bartender no no it
wasn't a very good bartender i actually
like i sort of i lied my way in my first
bartending job uh you know the problem
with barty so you have to have
experience to be a bartender but you
know no one's got to experience before
you've ever had experience right so you
got to sort of lie your way in
so i said that i had worked at some bar
it was a made-up place and uh
and and then you know you have to sort
of learn on the go so what i would do
was when people would ask me for a drink
that i didn't know how to make i would i
would make the drink and what i thought
i you know was and then i'd give it to
him and if they complain i'd say well uh
you know that's that's uh not how uh
that's how we make it here yeah yeah
that was not a convincing lie at all
that was uh that was uh
would you ever be getting clues from
them about how to make that drink like
just by asking them probing questions oh
yeah you want the old rusty scupper huh
well yeah that's interesting yeah you
like ginny
well see the thing is my partner by the
way is from the 1920s yeah okay
the bartender's always right the barter
is always right yeah you know if they're
even if they're wrong you know you'd ask
you know they'd ask for a shot and if i
didn't know you'd say you know hey what
color is that and then i would just add
some cranberry juice or something
you sound like you sound like a totally
inept bartender you sound like totally
the worst bartender ever first was any
was there even any liquor in half the
drinks you're probably yeah just had a
bottle of robitussin back there there
you go
that'll clean up the sinuses